the reason most people aren't successful  is they just can't [ __ ] control  themselves like that's it it's impulse  control they did this research study  that said that ultra successful people  have three common traits number one is  they have a superiority conflicts they  think they're better than everybody they  think they can do bigger things second  they have crippling insecurity of not  being enough that one hits me and then  the third one is impulse control so they  know where they want to go they have a  way drive to not be a failure and they  stay focused on it because of impulse  control i guarantee you if you delayed  your ass for five years and you just  provided value to people you have bigger  [ __ ] audience than you what to do  with but guess what no one's gonna do it  and that's why most people are  successful